ما يكشف أيضًا عن أندرسون هو كيف
يبدو أن ترامب بحاجة إلى محاولة إقناع
بوب وودوارد بما في ذلك في بعض الأحيان
إخباره بمعلومات سرية
قمت ببناء نظام سلاح
لم يكن لدى أي شخص في هذا البلد قبل
أن يكون لدينا أشياء لم ترها
أو تسمعها.  حول أن لدينا أشياء
لم يسمع بها بوتين ولم تسمع عنها من قبل قبل
التوافق مع روسيا أمر جيد
وليس شيئًا سيئًا ،
خاصةً لأن لديهم
1332 رأسًا نوويًا سخيفًا من الرؤوس الحربية ، من المضحك
أن العلاقات التي
أملكها أقوى وأقصد من هم  كلما
كنت أفضل ،
ستوضح لي ذلك يومًا ما ، حسنًا ، لكن ربما ليس
بالأمر السيئ ، فالأشياء السهلة هي
التي ربما لا تحبها كثيرًا أو
لا تتوافق مع ما
يقول وودوارد إنه كان كذلك  لم يتمكن أبدًا من
التحقق من نظام الأسلحة Anderson ،
لكنه يستخدمه كمثال على مدى
خطورة Cavalier العرضية التي يتم
اقتباسها من Woodward أن ترامب يدور حول
معلومات سرية ، كما يحتوي الصوت على معلومات
أخرى  موضوع متكرر
يخبرنا ترامب مرارًا وتكرارًا وودوارد
بمدى قوته ، لا
يوجد أحد أقوى مني ،
ما هو أصعب مني ، تسألني عن
المساءلة أنا تحت المساءلة
وقلت إنك تعلم أنك تتصرف وكأنك
قد فزت للتو  مخاطرة كان نيكسون في
الزاوية وإبهامه في فمه ، نعم ، لقد
أخذ بيل كلينتون الأمر صعبًا للغاية ،
فأنا أفعل الأشياء بشكل جيد ،
إنها كلاسيكية ترامب أندرسون أفعل ما
أريد القيام به بالطبع ، إنه أيضًا تذكير صارخ
برئاسة ترامب كما
هو  يطفو أنه يريد الركض مرة أخرى
في عام 2024